the history of the project of the atom
bomb is extremely interesting not only
for the physics and the chemistry that
was involved but the deep moral question
that has always worried me that if I had
been a scientist during the second world
war would I have worked on nuclear
weapons and I don't know what the answer
to that is did all the scientists who
were working on nuclear weapons know
they were working on nuclear weapons I
believe that most of the scientists
working on nuclear weapons realized what
they were doing I was taught by one
chemist alpha Maddock who worked on
plutonium on the chemistry plutonium you
can see on one of our videos me telling
the story how he dropped the entire
British reserve of plutonium which at
that time was only ten milligrams on to
the bench and burnt the bench to get it
back again and certainly one British
physicist who I knew who worked on
uranium enrichment as a young student on
the Manhattan Project knew exactly what
was going on and was really surprised
and enormous ly distressed when the bomb
was actually let off it is an atomic
bomb
it is a harnessing of the basic power of
the universe he thought that it would
merely be used as a threat and the
threat would be so powerful that it
would never need to be used the camera
was six miles away when that picture was
taken so the sound was delayed of course
smoke clouds rose to 40,000 feet
professor obviously the Manhattan
Project was incredibly secretive did the
different protagonists in World War two
a guess or expect that the other side
was trying to build this bomb because it
wasn't like it it had been theorized
that such bombs were possible would the
other sub would that would the opposing
sides have been thinking oh I wonder if
they are working on something or not
like was it was speculated that such
things were likely to be in development
I think certainly the British and
American scientists thought that the
Germans were working on the atom bomb
and in fact they thought they had made
much bigger advances than it turned out
they actually had done and if you watch
our video about the Russian physicist
flew off you will see that he guessed
that American and British scientists
were working on a bomb because in the
early 1940s these people who'd been
publishing lots of paper alerts on
nuclear fission suddenly stopped and he
wondered why these famous physicists
stopped publishing and then he thought
they must be making a bomb and in fact
he wrote to Stalin saying that the
Russian should also start making a bomb
so I think there was some awareness I
have no idea whether scientists in Japan
had any idea about this or not
he came here oh yes this is his lab coat
we'll see a big man yeah just like me me
and also a B what was once a meeting
here
sometimes he like we have the feelings
and to change the subject of the
discussion it's very much typical for
flora